Static Shock returns to television?
A secret crossover with Barbie?
What mysteries are hiding in
the dreams of "The Sandman?"
When we first meet Johanna Constantine, she's
on her way to a church for some light exorcism
under the pretext of officiating a
clandestine wedding. When she arrives,
instead of marrying the couple,
she speaks a Latin incantation
that forces a demon from the possessed
groom. Things get messy from there.
Once the demon erupts from the man he possessed,
Dream arrives and identifies him as Agilieth.
Before Dream can get the information
he needs, Johanna completes her spell,
and forces the demon back to Hell,
much to our main character's annoyance.
Agilieth doesn't appear in "The Sandman" comics,
but fans of John Constantine may recall him from
"Hellblazer " #196. In that issue, John is deeply
unfocused after recovering from being hypnotized,
and he's unable to recover his memories. He
stumbles upon a horrific scene where demons
sit around a table eating people. At the head
of the table is Rosacarnis, who welcomes him,
but Agilieth has other ideas. He stands, defying
John despite his host's insistence to sit down.
Rosacarnis rips the demon apart from the
inside, destroying him at John's feet.
One of the recurring themes of "The Sandman"
is that everyone gets a single life to live,
and then they die and move on.
For some, it's Hell, for others,
it's the Silver City. Those are two examples
of many. As far as the Dreaming is concerned,
when a person dies there, they can become
a raven, as demonstrated by Matthew.
But there are exceptions. Hob Gadling lucked
into immortality by becoming the focus of a
bet between Dream and Death, but he's not
the only immortal human in the series.
Another immortal soul is briefly seen in
Episode 3, and that would be Mad Hettie.
She meets Johanna Constantine and
tells her that Morpheus has returned.
"He's no fairy story, missy. He's
back, and he wants his sand."
Most viewers probably wondered who this woman is
and how she could know anything about Morpheus'
activities. Mad Hettie is actually more
than two hundred years old, born in 1741,
and like Mr. Gadling, she didn't think dying
was all that interesting a prospect. To avoid
her eventual demise, she hid her heart from Death,
literally. She's been labeled a "witch" over the
years and does know some basic magic. She pops up
occasionally to interact with John Constantine,
just as she does with his female counterpart
in "The Sandman" series. Other than offering
up her incredible age, she tends to keep
her most important secrets to herself.
When the Corinthian leaves Jed
in the hotel room in Episode 9,
Jed is watching cartoons on television.
On the screen a few characters flash by,
revealing that he's enjoying an episode of
"Static Shock" called "Toys in the Hood."
In the episode, the Toyman arrives in Static's
hometown of Dakota and attempts to capture Darci.
This is important because Darci is an
android created by the Toyman. However,
she seems to have developed a mind of her own and
distances herself from the creepy ne'er-do-well.
After Toyman successfully abducts Darci, Static
goes searching for her. He's soon joined by
Superman and the two team up for the episode.
It doesn't take long for the heroes to learn
that the Toyman's plot isn't what it appears. His
true motive is to capture Static's friend Daisy.
The Toyman and Darci plan to use Daisy's body as
a template so that the android can become human.
Several elements of the cartoon align with
Jed's story in "The Sandman." Like Daisy,
Jed is caught between two powerful forces. On the
one side, the manipulative Corinthian hopes to use
Jed for his nefarious purposes, and on the other,
stands Jed's sister Rose and her friend Gilbert.
The two are working together to try and
save Jed. Of course, there's more going on,
but the crux of the "Static Shock" episode
parallels the events of the episode.
As Dream and Matthew are escorted through Hell,
they happen upon a woman locked inside a cage.
When Dream sees her, the two have a short
conversation, and it's clear from their talk
that they have a long history. Dream, who Nada
knows as "Kai'ckul," reveals that they haven't
seen each other in 10,000 years. She begs for
Dream to free her, but he's not yet ready.
"I still love you, but I
have not yet forgiven you."
His response is chilling and taken directly
from the comics. The scene will leave viewers
wondering how Morpheus could be so callous to
a woman he loves, but there is an explanation.
Nada's damnation came about following a brief
affair between her and the Dream Lord. She tracked
Dream to the Dreaming and confessed her love for
him, but fled after discovering that he was an
Endless. Filled with passion, Dream followed her
to the Waking World and rekindled her affection.
While making love on a hill outside her city, a
meteorite slams into her home, destroying everyone
and everything. The devastation consumes Nada and
she commits suicide before Dream can stop her.
Morpheus follows her into the afterlife and asks
her to return with him. After refusing twice,
he tells her if she does it again,
he'll damn her to Hell, which he does.
Eventually, Dream comes to terms with Nada's
actions after an ordeal with a demon and places
her soul in a newborn baby. Then he tells Nada she
can return to the Dreaming whenever she wishes.
When Rose's abilities as a Dream Vortex begin to
manifest, she finds herself inside the dreams of
her friends who live with her in a quaint
house in Florida. Each of the residents'
dreams is important to the story, but one
stands out from the rest. Her friend Barbie's
dream seems to have a long history filled with
familiar characters and a developing story.
In the dream, Barbie is on a quest with a
traveling companion called Martin Tenbones,
who mentions something called the "Porpentine."
Assuming the show stays true to the comics,
this should become important to the story
following the events of "The Sandman" Season 1.
Barbie's dream, Martin Tenbones, and the
Porpentine all set up the comics arc titled
"A Game of You." The fairytale-like environs
of Barbie's subconscious are layered with
complexity and go back to her childhood. She
dreams of a magical world called The Land,
where she's a deposed princess fighting against
the evil abstract being known as the Cuckoo.
As Barbie matures, her dream continues, but
everything falls apart after she witnesses her
husband Ken having sex with a dream woman.
Barbie eventually moves to New York City,
where she no longer dreams,
leaving The Land in disarray.
As The Land crumbles, Martin Tenbones
breaks into the Waking World looking
for Barbie's help. Perhaps we'll see this
storyline in future seasons of the show.
Jenna Coleman's casting as Johanna Constantine
is a change from the source material,
as she replaces John Constantine from the
comics. They're more or less the same character,
and Coleman plays a perfectly
damaged supernatural sleuth.
If you enjoyed seeing her as Johanna Constantine
in the third episode, it's something of a treat
to see her return in the sixth as the Lady
Johanna Constantine, her 18th-century ancestor.
She and her band of ruffians threaten
Morpheus and are quickly dispatched.
Later, Morpheus mentions seeing her once more,
explaining that she completed a task for him.
Constantine will likely return at some point down
the line because Lady Johanna's task is essential
to the overall story. In 1794, Dream calls in
a favor Constantine owes him and asks that she
rescue his son, Orpheus. Morpheus' son was ripped
apart at one point, but being immortal, continued
living as only a head. He was ultimately buried
in a pile of corpses from the French Revolution.
Johanna finds Orpheus' head and returns
it to Morpheus, completing her task.
After their deal is done, Lady Constantine goes on
with the rest of her life, keeping her family name
going so that one day, John Constantine could
be born. Lady Johanna died at the age of 99,
and Dream had her body interred near
Orpheus' temple on the island of Naxos.
In the fifth episode, "24/7," the character Judy
is introduced as a woman concerned over the state
of her relationship with her partner Donna. Judy
admits to hitting Donna during a tumultuous fight,
and all indications suggest their time
together is at an end. The episode becomes
a nightmare wrought by Dream's ruby, and
Donna is mentioned throughout the episode.
In Episode 7, the Corinthian picks up a
photograph of Judy in Rose Walker's apartment,
showing that the two know each other. That's the
only reference tying the two together, but far
more is revealed in the comics. Donna's full name
is Donna Cavanagh, and she doesn't make her first
appearance until the issue, "Slaughter on Fifth
Avenue" during the "A Game of You" storyline.
Donna's backstory is expanded to explain her
relationship with Judy. After Judy's death,
she started going by the name "Foxglove,"
which she used in her singer-songwriter career.
She's one of the people living
with Barbie in New York City,
and she ventures into her dream to
help rescue Barbie from the Cuckoo.
Dream ventures into Hell with as
much respect for Lucifer as possible,
but things don't work out quite as intended.
He manages to embarrass Lucifer in Hell,
in front of every demon which doesn't sit well
with the Morningstar. After Dream leaves, Lucifer
promises to do something unprecedented that will
make God angry, and complete her ultimate goal.
"...and bring Morpheus to his knees."
If things play out as they did in the
comics, Lucifer's plan is well known.
In the books, Dream returns to Hell to
forgive Nada, but he finds the realm
empty. Only Lucifer remains, searching for any
lost souls or demons remaining in damnation.
Lucifer explains that it was time to quit being
the Lord of Hell, and he's ready for retirement.
Dream helps to cut off Lucifer's wings
and is left holding the key to Hell.
But this was Lucifer's plan: to saddle
Dream with the burden of damnation.
Lucifer explains that it was Dream who provided
the impetus to abdicate. Handing Dream the key,
Lucifer reminds him of the erstwhile vow
to destroy the Dream Lord, explaining,
"Perhaps it will destroy you,
and perhaps it won't. But I doubt
it will make your life any easier."
The "Sandman" comics go into detail
regarding the nature of the Endless,
who they are, and what they
do. The Netflix series only
offers a glimpse of the Endless with
depictions of Dream, Death, Desire,
and Despair. The Endless are the personification
of the concepts the siblings are named after.
The Endless are the masters of their own
domains, and Dream's is called the Dreaming.
There are others each member of the family
rules over, though Dream's is the one most often
visited by sentient beings. Most everyone
meets Death, but that happens only once,
while those who sleep spend a third of their lives
in Dream's realm, making him incredibly powerful.
Each member of the Endless has a gallery
within their realm. It's from the gallery
that they contact one another by holding their
siblings' sigil and asking for an audience.
Only Destiny can compel his siblings to a
meeting, whereas the rest must make a request.
The family consists of seven
members. In addition to Dream,
Death, Desire, Despair, and Destiny,
there's Delirium and Destruction.
If you pay attention to the galleries in the
show, you'll notice one portrait remains empty.
At several points throughout the first season
of "The Sandman," various members of the Endless
mention someone they call "the Prodigal."
It's never explained who they're referring to,
but it's something you can figure out
whether you've read the comics or not.
The name itself is a clue, as "prodigal"
means a son or daughter who abandons his
familial obligations to set out on
their own. Knowing this and seeing an
empty portrait in Dream and Desire's galleries,
it's clear the Prodigal is one of the Endless.
The comics reveal that the Prodigal is
Destruction, who goes by the name Olethros.
He is the only member of the family to abandon
his post, leaving his responsibilities behind.
This is why the Endless refer to
him as "Prodigal," and it's also
why his portrait doesn't hold
a sigil in anyone's galleries.
"The Prodigal has returned?"
"What? Oh. Him? No, no, he's still missing."
Destruction's purpose is to destroy
so new things can be created,
but he abandoned his responsibilities when
mankind turned towards science. Knowing
humanity would make new and horrific means of
destruction, Destruction opted to walk away,
which he did some time in the 17th century.
He fell off his siblings' radars and traveled
with a talking dog named Barnabas. He ultimately
turns up again, but his convictions never change.
At the end of Season 1, Rose leaves the Dreaming,
she awakens to learn that her friend Lyta has
given birth to a son. She meets the baby, but the
child doesn't have a name. Of course, the comics
spell it all out, and the child is incredibly
important to the story and Dream's fate.
The boy is named Daniel Hall, and as
you probably remember from the show,
Dream insists the baby is his. This
doesn't sit well with Rose or Lyta,
but it's not expanded upon, leaving
many wondering what he's talking about.
Daniel was created inside the Dreaming,
making him part of Dream's domain.
He's the son of Hector Hall, who in
the comics is known as Doctor Fate,
and Lyta, but he's destined for something more.
Dream is the one who names Lyta's son Daniel,
which she likes despite Dream's claim on
the child. It doesn't take long for Daniel
to manifest an ability to enter the Dreaming
in a manner far more lucid than most dreamers.
Ultimately, Lyta loses her sanity and seeks
out the Furies to exact their form of justice
on Dream. The Furies destroy Dream for
killing Orpheus, though he granted his
son a peaceful end. This in turn leaves
the role of Dream Lord open. Soon after,
Daniel artificially ages, and becomes
the new manifestation of Dream.